you
friendly Dean you mentioned that
nowadays the chemistry is in this
cyberspace I thought it's far away I
thought that chemistry is just in
laboratories well of course chemistry is
an experimental science but what has
happened over the past few years it's
it's really a fascinating development
when I was a young chemist theoreticians
would come to us with ideas about how
system behaved and if they if their
predictions would scan with our
experiments and they would be happy if
the two did not agree we were always
sure that that there are teachers were
wrong again today when theoreticians
come with the prediction that we cannot
prove is correct or disprove well
normally we as experimentalists go back
and check our experiments again because
it may just as likely be we who are in
the wrong today this is how far
theoretical chemistry has come to become
one of the tools i would say of
experimental science because the sort of
theoretical chemistry that this year's
low rates have been laying the
foundation for our simulations they're
really numerical experiments that tell
us a lot about how chemical systems work
so I would say to us Theory has become
the new experiments
what's happened then what made the
theory to be in this role now definitely
the contribution of this year's
laureates is central to that because
what they have done is marrying the two
worlds of quantum physics and classical
physics quantum physics will really
provide us with all the answers that we
could possibly look for quantum physics
has the wonderful ability to stop time
and to expand space so that we can look
at the tiniest detail of a system and we
can look at this during any fraction of
time that we choose the problem is that
the demands on computer power are
immense and it's completely impractical
to use this for any system of size
therefore we have to use classical
physics to describe the bulk of the
system and it turned out that to marry
these two is no simple matter and it
really took a large concerted effort
over a number of years to show that it
was even possible which is of course
what the laureates get quantum physics
is a lot about probabilities and mystics
is this a difficulty yes quantum physics
is one way of parameterizing the world
classical mechanics is a completely
different way of giving a model for
basically the same system now one thing
is that you can make the two and compare
them and that works beautifully the
problem is to take one part of a system
and describe it in terms of quantum
physics and another part of the
chemistry of the system and describe it
in terms of classical physics you then
have to find the correct boundaries to
put between the two systems and to use
the input from the classical mechanics
as boundary conditions for the quantum
mechanics
and vice versa and this means that we
can look at systems of I shouldn't say
any size but we can look at vastly more
larger systems and more complicated
systems and this is of course what we
need in order to understand the systems
that chemists are studying today huge
supramolecular systems biochemical
molecules large assemblies in material
science and all these disciplines use
the theory that was that was founded by
our three laureates it is really a
cross-disciplinary part of chemistry
which goes into all the fields and in
rich's them that doesn't mean that if
you don't have this theoretical model
you don't really understand what's going
on it's always a question of complexity
if you have a simple system you can get
very dependable answers by using just
experiment but experiment and physics
sorry experiment and theory go hand in
hand we need to understand why things
happen we need to understand what makes
things happen and as guna kallstrom was
was explaining during during his resume
of the price the real problem is that
most chemical methods tell us about what
things look like before a reaction and
what they look like after reaction there
is a there is a classical picture of
this which is given in many textbooks of
chemistry where a chemical reaction is
likened to a piece of drama and if you
go in and make the measurements before
and after it's like seeing the actors
before Hamlet and all the dead bodies
after and then you wonder what happened
in the middle and actually there is some
interesting action there and this is
what theoretical chemistry provides us
with
the whole drama so you want to be in the
eye of the storm absolutely but what are
the possible applications of the photos
and benefits right they're not they're
not possible they are there already
today there is not a pharmaceutical
company that doesn't have a theory
division that works on trying to predict
how a molecule will interact with the
target in the body this means that all
old development of new pharmacy
Pharmaceuticals has a background in
theory when you are looking at devising
new chemical reactions when you are
trying to to create a new hard material
or a new material specific properties if
you want to to optimize the electronic
and the electronic properties of
material the magnetic properties of
material you always start out with
theory because it saves you so much time
in the lab now theory is not perfect you
still have to do the experiment but the
predictions that theory make are
becoming so much more powerful these
days that we can perhaps save ninety
percent of the experimenting and
concentrate on the ten percent where we
know that the most important results
were like so we save a lot of money we
save a lot of time and we save a lot of
effort by doing the theoretical homework
first it's like in the old days when
everyone told you you have to read the
literature now everyone will tell you
you have to make the calculations so now
you just sit by the computer instead of
being in the lab yes there is there is
some truth in that although of course
what happens is that we can now turn to
other more complex systems we can always
devise a system that is so complicated
from the experimental point of view that
theorists still are struggling to keep
up with us but on the interim but on the
other hand they keep challenging our
if you look at at the physics price for
graphene for example now the
extraordinary properties of graphene
were predicted before by theorists this
is why the experimentalists tried to
make the material because it's no simple
matter to make it they tried to measure
the properties because they knew that
there was something interesting in there
and they succeeded but it was all thanks
to the theory that someone even tried so
here in the experimental where they
really do thank you very much for making
up I thank you